cécile aubry bonjour toujours que
reste-t-il de bas n'ont rien du tout
faits ils vont pas parler de choses qui
se sont passées à 25 ans enfin c'était
une aventure des dents les sens et
d'ascq est je crois un très beau film
vincent sébastien puis maintenant hervé
c'est votre nouvel héritier s'est à
nouveau petit héros et enfin jeune héros
il à elle quand même 14 ans et lui il a
une vocation du marin et il est il est
très breton cerveau s'appelle hervé la
nausée brousse c'est ça vous me parlez
cécile aubry vous le pensez on a envie
de vous demander comment va bibis fait
un média grandi je veux dire en ce
moment le futon belle et sébastien repas
sa télévision à l'heure des jeunes il
avait sept ans à l'époque maintenant il
y en a 18
c'est très différent et belle-fille son
droit il a passé son bac il son droit il
a tourné un film drogue du tout pour les
enfants il s'appelle catherine et
compagnie à jane birkin et puis à notre
avec brialy mais déjà longtemps
s'appeler un amour de pluie pour
l'instant il pense pas du tout à être
acteur il pense surtout à être metteur
en scène
avec beaucoup de chance sinon ma quant à
nous deux c'est un peu fini l'équipe
chacun fait un bon soir pour l'instant
comme moi j'écrivais des jours des
bouquins ça change pas et lui
j'espère qu'un jour il fera défi mais
qui sait je vais peut-être pu servir de
comédienne à jour joie les grands mères